birthday
s
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
ERS paid 25k to join and hang out with
some awesome humans Joe's got a new book
out called what's in it for them we've
got to hear we're not allowed to touch
that apparently is but we'll just we'll
just look and point to it it looks nice
the team doesn't want us to pick it up
uh Joe's been called the most connected
human on the planet
so maybe we'll start there because you
don't like to refer to yourself as that
but but it's in the book and you've been
called that how does that make you feel
well my
requires that sort of acknowledgment and
edification in order for me to feel like
I'm a complete human being no it's
a PR right
um
people is probably because I was alone
introverted
person kid growing up and I didn't know
how to really make friends uh you know
as I got older like high school I never
went to a prom or anything because I was
definitely afraid of asking anyone out
on a date and so
I think any
people came out of my own need to be I
was disconnected and so I was so
disconnected that you know drug addict
and I yeah I just did not connect so
it makes me feel really good that I can
bring people together and identify them
and
help help tie together this person can
help that person and most of it's based
on on him on human suffering that's
that's pointed as I look I look pain
be solved in the other side no it's
great when people did but I would never
describe myself that way because there's
certainly a hell of a lot more people
that are more connected than I am
you've helped me in a lot of ways that
you didn't need to you
invited me to stay at your home you know
in the middle of a giant event that
you're putting on
you're not going I don't think to the
calculus of oh if I invite them over to
my house then maybe with an interview or
a book comes out next year is it just in
your nature now to offer to help like it
doesn't make sense to do the things that
you do and it ends up paying out in the
long term so is it just that that's
become who you are in your nature or how
would you describe the process well if
there was a therapist that was
describing me they could either look at
attachment disorders or codependency or
just someone that's just trying to be
used
think
I think there's a karmic value in
being a helpful generous grateful human
as much as possible and I don't look at
usefulness like Fine China where you
only got a limited Supply that doesn't
mean you can't deplete yourself because
I certainly
have cared more about other people's
issues or things than they've either
cared about them
to think in a lot of ways to take that
from recovery you know I've spent many
years in in recovery
approach a recovery of addiction so when
I say a recovery I was
I can do still I
lied as an addict
and the reason I you know like that
that distinction is addiction to me is a
solution to pain and there's there's
very similar
connection and addiction are very
similar you know Johann Hari has that
line the opposite of
addiction is connection
you know and so with with me uh
going to 12-step groups as an example
I've actually stepped in rooms where
there were other people there that
believed in me more than I believed in
myself
so I hope in the in the right way heals
hope used in the wrong way is actually
very destructive so hope is a very
interesting
sort of thing and so yeah I go into
things without agendas I think for every
what I've learned over the years though
and what what's in it for them is really
about is
not just capabilities but character
it's not just uh
being helpful and useful for people
because if you do that you're probably
gonna have a lot of friends you know
because How to Win Friends and Influence
People I even say that in the beginning
of the book if it was not for Dale
Carnegie's book I never would have
written this book that book is fantastic
everyone should read How to Win Friends
and Influence People and so felt that it
needed an update because you can win the
wrong friends and influence the wrong
people so it's like how do you win the
right friends and influence the right
people so that your time attention money
effort and energy is spent connecting
with people that are worth connecting
because if you don't value your time and
and your money and your effort and your
energy
and your usefulness and you score
people that don't appreciate it then
you're not able to have that same energy
invest
the care so I do look ings as an
investment I certainly want to feel good
out of it I want people to like me
there's all of these human things but I
also think that
assistive producers and parasites and I
want to produce more than I consume and
I want to help givers of the world be
affected and better boundary givers and
to help people avoid takers and so for
me I feel every time I'm helping someone
without an agenda it's kind of putting
something in my
it's like an it is a deposit of an
investment so that's why I look at it
and if I ever have a tinge of
selfishness or like I want something or
I feel like oh you know I'm really doing
this because I'm trying to position
myself and certainly I have all
I mean I
yeah I want I want stuff everybody wants
something I mean no one would be in this
group if they didn't want anything you
don't
need 25 000 or 100 Grand a year to come
to genius Network then have to take the
time
to travel here and all the other if you
don't want anything uh you know so we
all want something you know I would
right before lunch I wanted to eat lunch
I was hungry it says does your when you
show up with a want from someone
make sure that your give is bigger than
you want
and so if
people really appreciate you because a
lot of people show up with a want but
they have no give to give you they just
it's purely want and so there's nothing
wrong with wanting something there's
nothing wrong with pursuing
opportunities but there's a big
difference between
you know pursuing an opportunity versus
being an opportunist there's a different
energy with someone that's just trying
to you just know that everything about
it is kind of fake and so I really
do my best to not be in that world and
to not have agendas and at the same time
if there is an agenda it's you know
likability it's you know hopefully it
will nurture a relationship I want to be
connected
solo creatures yeah and I was on an
island once where we were and and
they're telling me about a guy who
actually lived on this island with his
dog by himself for something like 10
years and he eventually
sounds creepy as hell but he ended up
killing his dog and eating his dog he
went mad because you're not supposed to
humans are not designed to just be alone
yeah and that was like this
great tangent I didn't tell that story
[Laughter]
so you're honestly one of the most kind
and caring and giving people that I know
skeptical people that I know
and you look at the story of Andre
Norman who's in the house and in the
first five minutes of meeting him you
offer to pay for his expenses for the
next five months
how do you make the decisions for
anybody who's trying to give and help
and support do you just have a really
good BS filter at this point like what
do you recommend for people so that they
don't get taken advantage of well look
at every area taking advantage of
Patrick gen Tempo actually gave me a
great framing of this is like red flags
are easy to notice uh we can all see red
flags it's the yellow flags that we
often don't pay attention to and so
people are always putting out
real flags and others are putting out
green flag so with the Andre thing in
the very beginning of my career
I had to get taken advantage of many
times and I had to deal with a lot of
Scoundrels in order to develop my Spidey
senses and
recently where someone that I helped
make rich I helped make famous I
introduced symptoms you know and then
the person ended up being one of the
biggest narcissistic con men that I'd
ever met and so and and then I
associated with
this war of the same
of the same realizing in the very
beginning so it's it's unfortunate I
think most people don't know how to uh
how to size up
fake people inauthentic people uh
narcissists takers unless you have been
taken to the cleaners a few times
and so for me
I could with Andre I was you know we're
talking years of experience with stuff
to actually sit down with a guy and get
a sense is this guy real or not but I
didn't
you know I didn't 100 know and I also
know that
as humans we sometimes when we're doing
well we're caring we're generous we're
giving we're compassionate we're
empathetic and other times we're
self-centered we're
so mean we're
interested or self-absorbed and it just
happens to be what's going on
biochemically if you have desperation in
your life if you have massive complexity
if you're super overwhelmed so I now can
size up many things very quickly
but I also still it's really easy as a
Giver if you are a giver if you
genuinely a giver the people that don't
like me uh my rationale and excuses that
they're all takers
so if I rub someone the wrong way
in all seriousness there is some truth
to that because I do try to call out
behaviors of takers and and
and I'll get to that in a moment with
with me I just sit and think okay uh I
don't say yes as quickly as I used to I
have the thing that makes me feel good
in the moment where I get a dopamine hit
is saying yes
but then it gives me an obligation so
I'm very careful to just offer uh help
to someone multiple times if I don't see
them exhibiting
appreciation and I like really
reciprocal people so my experience with
you super cool reciprocal helpful person
and I from the very beginning
oftentimes ingenious hour people will
get annoyed that one person is getting
more attention to another and they think
there's favorism but what they don't see
behind the scenes is what that person is
actually doing to contribute
to you to want to help I've had other
people that are teaching professional
speakers how to speak you know we have
Joel Weldon who's sitting here in the
room today and they don't see all of the
volunteer work that it got without being
asked for that Joel's morning it's the
same with you I mean every meaning you
know like what can I do to help
that's just who you are and so I
resonate with that because that's how I
am you know and
so that's that's uh that's kind of how I
think about it and I will say I I say
this in my book
I try to give
a road map for how to navigate it is how
to deal with people that try to
intimidate you how to set up boundaries
as best you can how to protect yourself
from from takers because I want to
better boundary uh help people think
about boundaries and if you are a giver
you are going to be taken advantage of
and you already have and it's going to
happen again in the future so how do you
recover from it and how do you keep
using it to build up because what do you
do say no I'm not going to give to the
world anymore because you know this
person took advantage of me I mean
that's one way that some people try to
protect themselves from it but you know
we're gonna if
do a gun fight with fight without a gun
so if you're going to play the game make
sure you know the players the game or
don't play the game because some games
are just rough
some people are sharks it's funny they
have Shark Tank you know and a lot of
it sounds kind of interesting and
there's a bit of a performance because I
know you know a few of the sharks on
Shark Tank are friends
and
you know the fact is uh
how to swim with the sharks they'll be
named alive my buddy Harvey McKay wrote
that book many years ago he's about to
turn 90 years old
um but you know
oftentimes you don't need to go into a
bloody shark infested place in order to
get what you want in life but if you're
going to take on big problems and big
challenges
you're going to get kicked out of
everyone's everyone so let's avoid the
unnecessary ones you know because the
game's hard enough as it is
people playing games and life constantly
to you know it's not yeah it's like I
want to meet someone that doesn't play
games
good luck that planet does not exist
what people are really saying is like I
don't want I want to be people don't
play games what they're really saying is
I don't want to lose the game because if
you're winning the game you play games
all day long it's fun to play a game you
love winning so the question is though
some relationships you will never win
because they're not in the hit for you
to ever win they don't want you to win
they just want everything for themselves
so
you you know help me so much that last
year when you took a sabbatical
uh I took it personally not that I was
angry at you more that I don't want his
business to fall apart while he's gone
it felt like it became my responsibility
for whatever reason to make sure that
whatever I could do to help so showing
up to every meeting doing lunch YouTube
sessions with people
because of all the value that you
created and now you've kind of codified
the rules in the book for how people can
do that you talk about okay we know the
right flag so we can't find the yellow
or that's the hard part so what are the
what are some of the yellow flags to pay
attention to well you know Chris Voss
who went through my elf versus half
system and he's writing about it in his
new book and it's so funny Chris like
calls me one day he's like I want to
write a chapter about elf versus half in
my book you know in his last book is
sold nearly
he's like with it okay if I would would
that be okay I know my own no that would
really suck I don't want any of that I
don't want any of that PR Chris that
would that would yeah
um but like with someone right out of
the gate
much money you're going to make together
or how they
uh a lot of its energy I mean it's not
what someone says it's the tone most
conflict is not what someone says it's
the total
there is a tone that there's a feeling
so some of the red flags are just how do
you feel
and one of the things I describe is be
the type of person you want to answer
the phone for so someone call
text you or however they get a message
to you
and your body is feeling like rejecting
them before you even call it there's an
energy that you're like but when someone
that you're excited you know where they
call you like I really
really looking at how
feel
in their presence and my buddy Derek
sivers you know and uh this is mentioned
earlier today where I didn't want to
talk so you know it's either hell yes or
no some people are just hell yes their
energies hell yes their enthusiasm uh
yo
very much about positioning and
posturing I really look at my gauge of
red flags the easiest for me when it
comes
there are Betty business relationships
that I have with people that I don't
really would want to be personal friends
with him uh and and you don't often know
that until you hang out with them for a
period of time and because everyone can
be on their best behavior like is anyone
in the room ever did an interview with
someone and the interview was awesome
and then once you hired them
they didn't match the interview at all
right their behavior didn't match what
they promised or you bought something
from a marketer who used really hypey
marketing and then what you bought it it
didn't live up to the hype like at all
so how you know
people that are more full treat people
that are less powerful to them that's
the biggest red flag to me they go out
to a restaurant do they how do they
treat the servers you know the how if
someone opens the door for them do they
say thank you
when it comes time for the bill do they
offer to pay even if you know you're
going to pay it do they even have the
courtesy or the social intelligence to
say hey let me get this or hey can I
contribute or they just expect you to
pay for
like you know all of those things go
through that before you ever do a big
business deal with someone just simply
see how do they treat their team how
like there are people that are super
nice to me but then they'll yell at my
to be abusive I cannot tell we've I've
probably fired oh God in the years I've
been doing this probably 40 people that
were super cool to me but abusive to my
staff and when I mean abusive not like
beating them up physically but just
being [ __ ] you know just being really
really and so those are the biggest red
flags to me is not you know because it's
really easy to for a narcissist to
mirror empathy because that's what you
see the the challenge with dealing with
narcissistic people and sociopaths and
Psychopaths is that they um and that
would
that would Encompass uh a good portion
of the many famous self-helperins but
the ones that really need
following is a big social media
following seeing others that you can
just see
but they don't have to waste any energy
caring about people and so they can make
a lot of money because you know you can
dance up on stage and act really goofy
who gives it you know how you feel you
don't care what anyone thinks but you
just care about crowd control you care
about you know uh hurting all of these
you know followers up and and having you
know your own little Messiah complex and
so when when you uh when you can see
that in other people those are big red
flags I mean I
do some background checks but in super
Charming people super articulate
Charming people uh can oftentimes be a
red flag you know you're talking about
being an introvert and I think people
who may not know you would think how is
the most connected person on the planet
self-proclaimed but not an introvert and
that's something that I struggled with a
lot you know as somebody who had no need
to be famous and introverted
the story always tell myself oh I can't
move to networking events and I can't
make connections and
introvert so has that helped you that
the strategies work regardless how did
you overcome it what goes through your
mind thinking I'm an introvert is going
to go make connections well here's the
thing so I so I recently did an
interview with Neil Strauss right and in
his the game uh which is a book on on
uh you know uh pickup artists uh he has
this term which is Rapport is trust with
comfort so when you have rapport with so
many not only how it's it's not just
trust but they have comfort with
to be in rapport with other
you're either
communicating you're connecting or
you're trying to escape you
so most interactions in life
communicating with someone
if you are in sync with them if you're
same interest simply then you're
connecting or you're just trying to
escape and so I would often look at
interactions where I'm like man I'm
a person or is it because of my own
fears my own narratives that I make up
with uh growing up I would read all of
these books trying to books on shyness
books on being assertive because I just
could not bring myself to ask for things
and
I formulated this whole idea that you're
either uh you know you're either uh
going to be
incapable of pursuing
thing or you're going to be
going to be pursuing things with fear
and to bring up Neil Neil like he was
definitely afraid of women right and a
lot of the people that were in the
community they they wanted to you know
now they framed around how to you know
pick up women and and it was not really
about like the pickup guys are good at
getting phone numbers and having sex and
doing all that and and they're different
than the relationship people so so
person relationship marketers
the transaction business of the
transformation business and so uh some
of the best pickup guys you
and gals but mostly guys
they're not probably the best at
developing long-term relationships
they're kind of like two different skill
sets so the things that will get you to
one point may not get you to another so
there's there's different phases of it
so
talking to someone though in the
beginning if you can't even approach
somebody and you can't even talk with
them and you can't even connect with
them then you're never going to get
anywhere else with them with them so
what I
learned is that
whatever I fear
in my life controls me whatever I fear
well if I fear it and don't face it it
controls me whatever I fear and face it
or at least take steps to face it that I
can eventually control it and then I
realize that asking someone
out not to you know if you care I think
if if you're if you're not a void of
caring person
and there's something that you want you
can be nervous as heck the man's talking
to Cherie yesterday about a person who's
literally
doing one of the most riskiest things in
the world
afraid to ask someone that he's
interested in out on a date it just he
cannot bring himself and this is a
person that is doing something that is
so incredibly difficult uh
I wish I could again
I mean it's something that may change
the world what this person is working on
but he's
he cannot ask his object of Interest
right now out on a date without being
deathly afraid so I realized that
everyone has fears including me some of
them are real some of them are just
manufactured and it's my alibi and so I
so when I was scared I'm like okay
but I'm never going to get anything done
in the world I'm never going to create
anything if I don't go and develop
relationships with people so I
I practiced and I practiced and I
practiced and I I still every time I
have to step in front of a group of
people to do a public speech I'm nervous
I have butterflies in my stomach to a
degree but I've learned to party with it
you know you just gotta party with the
fear because it will either control me
quit caring about about it then
something's wrong the moment I
that's my I'm not saying that
people I truly
I truly don't get bothered by by certain
stuff and other people do but for me uh
yeah I I just wanted to meet people and
even though it was painful it's like
getting into a cold plunge
in the beginning oh my God it sucks it's
awful but then the more you do it and
you get the dopamine you're like wow I
actually feel better there's and we got
Michael and Jesse who you know own
optimize here if both of them are here
today and
you know I mean I will probably go do a
cold pledge later today after this
because it would be really good for my
head if you
after I'm done doing it or after I'm
like about a minute but it's sitting in
that discomfort because you know the
Joseph Campbell line the cave you fear
to enter holds the treasure that you
seek and so there are caves always caves
in my life that I'm like I'm afraid to
go there but if I go there something's
going to come out of it and so
afraid of asking anyone out on a date I
had to frame it in my head as a teenager
I'm not taking it's not rejection it's
taken a survey of who has good taste and
who doesn't
so I don't fault of it but it was my
practice and you got to do the rest just
like Chris Voss says you got to do the
Reps no one's going to fly into flying
you got
ta you gotta
eventually maybe you can fly you know if
there's such a thing but you can't and
so everybody here has applied whatever
success they've had
uh and it's a skill it's a skill that
can be learned uh and as far as
introvert and extrovert I think there's
different places where I'm an introvert
and other places where I'm an extrovert
in my own environment here it's a lot
easier than if I to go into some
of them when I used to
sco State University people thought I
was going there today to get some sort
of college education I was really
changing the environment so I could get
from being a drug
and one of the jobs that I had was I was
selling
memberships in a gym and here I was this
skinny drug addict that it started
working out in a gym not doing personal
training because no one would have hired
me as a personal trainer I was selling
gym memberships and I would tour people
through the gym
sell them the them the future of where
they want to be no one wants to work out
they want
for them so talk you know and ask
in essence and I learned that
students are more important than answers
you'll learn a lot more about someone
through questions than you will just
pursue answers and what I noticed
because I was going to college I'd often
go to these bars and I would see these
big Meatheads that were lifting weights
in the gym that I sold memberships at
and they were super awkward they were in
the corner because the the gym was their
domain they were the Lions and they
ruled it but if you transplanted them in
a nightclub they
and they look
to ask any person that like long-haired
person that's in the club all day long
that's that's their domain but they
would feel like a total out EST person
at the gym and I realize every human has
places where they excel in other places
where they're terrified like okay
how do I practice in all kinds of
different places so I feel less
uncomfortable
but knowing that no matter what I'm
doing if I'm pursuing something that
there's always going to be a little bit
of uncomfortableness to it or a lot of
uncomfortableness and the opportunities
are in places where most people are
afraid to go
and your own success in life is going to
be those places you're afraid to go
where the biggest treasure lies going
back to the Joseph Campbell thing that
you know the KV feared after all the
treasure that you seek like the like
you've already accomplished something
amazing
what's the next Mountain
so if you had to coach that supers and
Tesla entrepreneur is going to change
the world and afraid to ask a girl
what are you telling them
you know
say instead of me having to take credit
for it Gretzky said it best you know you
missed 100 of the shots you don't take
you know you really do if you're not
willing you know
ask is a very important word if you if
you don't ask now the key though
asking how and how you position it I
mean in the beginning until you size up
a person and I even
see same as
people use it in evil ways
whoever cares the least controls the
relationship
in the beginning once you have rapport
with someone and you don't have to do
that anymore and you have a genuine
caring person you don't have to do
positioning posturing but if you never
develop
ships how many marketers out there with
all the hustling games and all of that
that they play they always live in that
world because they've never gone deep
enough with any relationship to where
it's not about positioning posture
posture so they think
a human in life needs to be a sales
pitch needs to be psyched an NLP
technique
everything they do is
Chef so I would tell the person to go
deep
to you know
willing to do the Reps and to ask and to
ask and show up as your best person and
don't
cheekling I mean like if you're a guy
and you really like a
well can we say guys and girls or how do
we identify this gender
I don't see I can make all kinds of
jokes right now but
if you want to drive someone away in the
very beginning that you're really
infatuated with send them roses and
flowers every day tell them how much you
love them three like immediately that
like in any woman here can know what
it's like okay it's it's it comes across
as needy and Desperation so there are
ways that you have if you're scared and
I do go deeper in this in
taught this in the book on how to hand
a half future Pace you know you know
they're gonna think of me and then what
happens is you aren't even yourself
because you're so projecting this
narrative that you've made up in your
own because so much of it is just just
psychological interpretation and you
have to be willing to uh you know the
Theodore Roosevelt you know the the
credit goes to the person that's in the
arena not the person that's observing it
you think about like I'm like I'm Sports
I had a sadistic little league coach
that forced me to hold the baseball bat
in a way that I could not hit I could
not could not hit the ball and I was not
not you smart ass adult that I am now uh
back then I was just a shy introverted
kid and he did he wasn't doing this to
any of the kids there that's weird
because I was like why
this guy why like what did I ever do to
this person and it literally ruined my
liking of of of sports and then I I quit
the uh I quit the team and uh I got
picked on and beat up by all the other
it was like this total no-win situation
and it just reinforce this and that Drew
even further
further in desperation and stuff and I
look at sports today and you know and
and
the interpretation of wealth it gives
people something to Rally around
how many people if you take like a
football team or a a baseball team or a
soccer team or you're you have in some
cases professional sports NASCAR please
don't help the biggest sport in the
United States of you
they
you have
thousands tens of thousands maybe
hundreds of thousands oftentimes like a
Super Bowl millions of people observing
the unique ability
to keep the players or you see an actor
or an actress or a performer people are
paying money to witness other people's
unique ability and what I took from it
is like well I don't just want to watch
the game
I want to be in the game I more
interested in playing
than watching and observing although I
love to watch unique ability like I love
Cirque du Soleil you know I think it's
cool you know you go and witness people
doing incredible things but I also know
that I'm with
other people's unique ability
Bill and part of it is to develop skills
like my friend Cal Newport says you know
they're
so good they can't ignore you well the
way to get
good at something
anything worth doing
is worth doing poorly
in the beginning
Because unless you're just one of these
unicorn talented people right out of the
gate just has a
an art or performance or singing or
you're gonna suck and so you know going
through the stages of working through
the burn you know the reason a lot of
people don't EX exercise and workout is
they can't handle the two weeks or the
four weeks of being sore as hell when
they start lifting weights they give up
because they can't put in two weeks of
working through the burn and so with
anything
is it developed you know so I would tell
the person work through the bird
because it's going to hurt and you may
get rejected
but who's rejecting who
are they rejecting you are you rejecting
you because every time we don't ask or
pursue something we really want is
really meaningful with good intentions
if you have good intentions behind it
you're not taking anything from the
world
what and and so if you
don't if you miss the shot that you
don't take
you missed the shot you didn't take if
you get rejected
so you don't ask someone out on a date
because they're going to reject you
who rejected who
you rejected you
so I want people to quit rejecting
themselves
and if you have gifts for the world
develop them and then ask people for it
and demonstrate it you know
you don't build a great reputation by
talking about what you're going to do
you build a great reputation by doing it
so the whole thing like
how many people here in the room have
amazing reputations not because they
wrote a sales letter you know some
people here could write a sales letter
have great reputations because they have
demonstrated they do it in the world so
you know one one of the best flag is the
person saying what they're doing do they
demonstrate what they're doing do they
do you know it's so easy today to find
out reputationally uh you know where
someone is you know talking to people
and there's nothing wrong like if
someone's approaching you with a you
know business deal there's nothing wrong
with uh scoping them out and then the
importance of it I would even go so far
as
private investigators to do background
checks and I'm not kidding on that
going to a serious relationship with
someone you know spend a couple hundred
bucks I mean or or five thousand you
know you know why would you go into
something that's going to be worth a
hundred grand or 500 Grand or a million
bucks to not know who the hell you're
dealing with you know if it's a new
reputation and rapport
happens sometimes pretty quickly but
trust takes a little bit more time you
have to spend time with someone not that
it can't be established quickly and
that's the beauty of you know Charles
was earlier talking about
you know the
these of Joy Ventures taking this to a
marketing type of
example
is I would you know I originally taught
carpet and upholstery cleaners how to uh
you know Market themselves because I was
a was and I did everything my
system so once I figured out things that
worked for me I would teach them to
other people and I would often tell uh
you know the carpet cleaners the pad in
the business might be finding you know
an interior designer finding a carpet
retailer finding a house painter finding
a landscaper finding a pest control
company finding an electrician you
real estate person um
a dry cleaner of clothing that has
already developed
relationships with groups of people that
they can recommend your services to so
what you're doing you know my friend
until today that's kind
it's got to be it's like every host has
parasites so you want to be you want to
find the host and you want to latch on
to what they have you know like
you know because they just drain you so
part of uh part of the trust is you can
borrow trust so the beauty
an advantage is if you spend a lot of
time being a useful helpful person
other people start telling other people
about how you know we've got one of the
greatest marketing groups in the world
that's really a connection group
disguised as a Marketing Group
um
that I don't do a lot of marketing for
it's mostly word of mouth because people
are like I meet cool people there and
you know so it's one thing
from a
business standpoint
if you do if you do have people saying
glowing wonderful things about what you
do your products your services your team
your company then they're not giving you
glowing testimonials you need to really
look at
do we should happen now the danger of it
is
if your whole Pursuit like Dan Sullivan
says if you pursue growth versus or
status or two different things the
people pursuing status
they just want to be positioned in a
certain way they want people to think
about them and you can have a lot of
fake friends you can buy a lot of likes
you can buy a lot of PR you can you know
but the real
legitimate stuff is when people are
saying great things value and when
people you admire are saying great
things about you and I think
becomes a snowball when you start doing
stuff in the world and you have
developed a so let's take some Calgary
Port stuff you develop a skill that is
rare and valuable you know his whole
thing is don't pursue passion
but really pursue skills that are rare
valuable and then apply them in areas
where they're needed and will produce
results and if you do that long enough
you will get what he calls career
capital
and once you have career Capital you
then have control over your life
happens is people give up too quickly
before they're at the point to where
they have
career capital and they never have
control in their life
and I don't care if you run into company
or if you're an employee I mean if
you're an employee and you work at
company
find out for one what that company needs
what does that what does the oh like I'm
amazed that anyone in any company
could be on
heifer a generous caring person all they
need to figure out is what the hell
drives the person crazy and how to have
like less things trying crazy I write
about this in the book Gary Chapman who
wrote the five love language
and he was speaking
after he got off stage I went and met
him
like back uh not right backstage but
right around like an area because he was
going to go to another area and I was
talking with him
he said to me he goes you know if you
want you want to find out what someone's
love languages are listen to what they
complain about
and I was like that's a very interesting
thing see because most people tried like
don't don't complain you know like in
Dale Carnegie's book it's like there's a
chapter on never criticized condemn or
complain and I love to criticize
condemning complain but I do it in
joking ways because it's to me it's like
pitching in a circle
in a circle careful though because I can
go into RADS and just start whining
about however
complaints are really valuable like if a
customer see a customer they complain
how many of you have ever bought
something product or service from a
company
it's sucked you weren't happy with it
but you never said anything
you just said never gonna do business
with them again
now the reason why sometimes this is
such a low purchase you don't care other
times
you just knew that even if you said
anything about it it would be you know
uh it would be deaf ears
right and so
if a person takes the time to complain
about something they usually do it
because they feel on some level the
company is capable of doing something
about it and so complaints can actually
be really useful feedback on what to
improve now
criticism though a lot of people that
attack you and there is a lot of
jealousy and a lot of envy and that's
the one thing I want to prepare people
for too because if you are very
successful at what you do you will have
haters uh
criticism toxic criticism where it's not
just criticizing you or pointing
something out but it's really like
attacking that's usually self-hatred
turned outward so people that are the
biggest critics it's just their own
self-hatred and they turn it outward by
attacking other people and to know the
distinction with that when someone
complains though so if you work for a
company and your boss is bitching about
something all the time
like just ask them what drives you crazy
and if you can do anything you will
position yourself
at the top of their attention and so
part of relationship building is
positioning yourself at the top of
someone else's agenda and I think the
best way to do that is not through
manipulation in sales it's through
usefulness and generosity and
gratefulness because if if you if
someone really appreciates you like what
is the economic definition of
appreciation and depreciation right like
if you look at it from a
things that go up
go up and things that go down in value I
want to always be the person that things
go up in value as much as I can and if
there's no in in the best see the best
way to get good at selling business
where you're asking for money
like when there's no money involved just
see your ability to influence and
persuade people by being super nice to a
server or someone that's having a bad
day
bad day you know if you can just add
some sunshine I mean most people's lives
have a lot of darkness in it and you
know
in person like you take Joel welding he
has this whole thing I still have it
fully adopted that's you know making a
great day because I still kind of have
you know like have a good day have a
great day you know that's easier for me
to say that make it a great day but Joel
he's like make it a great day because
you have the control over this don't
just
leave it up to random Choice make it a
great day and you actually can we have a
lot of power we are the CEO of our life
and we're either writing a love story a
a drama
a romance a tragedy a comedy and
sometimes if you're a super add quick
start like most people in the room
you're doing all of those things by noon
every day you know you and so part of it
is what's the story you know what's the
love story and so uh
practice
practice on situations where it doesn't
matter if you get rejected and then when
it does matter to you and at the end of
the does it does any of it really matter
all that much so I
up into
um
you know something my buddy Dave kekich
who spent half his life in a wheelchair
would say he goes things are seldom as
Bleak as they seem when they're going uh
uh they seem when they're going well
lighten up you'll live longer
there's a balance in all of this
asking someone out on a date and them
saying no in the moment may feel like oh
God I mean I had to muster up all that
courage and I still got rejected but
again and then you can say you know
she's seriously uh
why'd you reject me but tell me the
truth and I would really appreciate it
and see if they most the time anyway
because I want to make you feel bad but
you'll often you'll often get you'll
often get what it
cars they lie with their plastic surgery
they lie with their hair and their
makeup and their shoes and their watches
and all this other humans are just
status pursuing creatures doing weird
stuff and once you realize that we're
just monkeys that drive cars uh it makes
all of this a lot more humorous and a
lot more fun
a way to deal with the pain of life I
don't think I'd be any good at
connecting if I didn't have so much pain
of disconnection and if you really want
to know the value of most relationships
look at people and see how often they
laugh together if you're sitting with a
couple and they're having dinner and
their display
looks and they're not able to have fun I
mean we you know people that Infuse if
you don't have a sense of humor and I
say this in the book take an improv
class go to clown school I mean
like like
loyal to be more funny go to go to
comedy shows watch you can watch online
for free just like watch comedy shows
and just
punk people
answer them like I have a great
relationship with Jennifer Hootie for
one we can jam on all kinds of creative
you know we're both quick start you know
crazy
entrepreneurs but she has such
inappropriate humor and we just we buy
two guys
you know it's like I love
I love the people that like get really
uptight about certain stuff huh you know
and again there's you know there's
there's there's they have their own
psychological issues to deal with too
but uh yeah laughter laughter laughter
brings
um brings relief and so all of this
being said one of the best ways to bond
with people is look for their pain
where are they hurting where do they
have pain be a pain detective can you
bring some relief
you bring some camaraderie to that pain
and I think we will connect more with
people through pain than we will through
pleasure
you talk about this group a couple times
so we're doing this that genius Network
it's one of the pieces of advice in the
book is to create your own genius
network if you're sure it says genius
Network my book says genus Network I'm
still a marketer I'm promoting and if
people have you know 25 000 you're an
entrepreneur
this genius Network for people who may
not be at that level yet how do we build
create find their own genius Network
they have to buy my book
uh you know if they don't want to want a
Kenny they can go to joe'sfreebook.com
and get my book for free life gives to
the giver and currently we don't have
some sort of like like self funnel that
submit Divine we don't
we don't book
a bunch of other stuff through like
clever marketing because a lot of people
give away free books and it's really a
crappy book but you're just going to get
into their upsell funnel uh we genuinely
give
I think it's a really good book and
people really love that book for free so
one of the ways that I address that most
of people that benefit from what I do
never pay me a penny they listen to my
podcast
add millions of dollars
of podcasts thanks to you we've built
we're building a really good YouTube
following I mean man I should have taken
your advice three years ago when you're
telling me stuff to do but
amazing
and doing stuff and I really appreciate
that
I put a lot of
stuff uh
in the book though the book actually
walks people through how to build a
genius Network because in order to have
a genius Network which is a group of
people that have skills and capabilities
solve most problems in the world
especially business problems
you have to in order to have a genius
net
you have to be a genius networker and
you have to do this networking
games networking principles to get what
you want by helping others get what they
want
principles
there's not any piece of knowledge that
I've ever put out into the world that
I've spent more time on than this book
and it was a team effort like I I
originally is a guy named Hal who helped
me with uh the first uh version of the
book and then I decided to redo the
whole thing uh and then I worked with JR
who's been on my team working with me
for over 12 years and
who helped me uh with the editing
and my whole team and I acknowledge
the book but I
uh all kinds of interviews every chapter
has dominoes because I think of the
first Domino you know so uh
I want to be a domino for people and I
want other people to be dominoes for
other people so like every
book or a piece of knowledge or
something that happened in your life
that changed the trajectory
of your life in good ways and in
negative ways like the sadistic little
she was a domino in a negative way it
caused me to really
association with sports but there were
many people that had been amazing
dominoes and the people that get my time
attention money effort and energy are
people that are dominoes to me that help
me make my boat go faster
I teach that story in there about the
2000 British rowing team and
so
I try to pack this book with as much
useful strategies and method and
interviews that they can access but the
book alone is a standalone I think it's
really good I don't really care about
hitting the list the book is not out at
the time
uh but I uh you know I just hope it is
around for decades I really I hope and
if not then I will
realize that I suck you know crawl into
a hole and I'll be depressed and
hopefully I won't relapse and go back
into addiction but I will I I I've
developed some tools so yeah my my
future sanity relies on anyone that
happens to hear this message
promote this book for free
to just think about what's in it for me
you really need to buy
yeah one more question before we throw
the Q a and anybody who wants to do q a
uh please use the microphones that we've
got and also this is one of my YouTube
channel so you'll be on YouTube some of
you might that might be an incentive and
that might be a disincentive so just
leave it with you there so you sent out
a newsletter yeah so genius networking
letter and in it you said the truth is
almost everyone who puts out a podcast
or writes a book myself included is
doing their own form of therapy correct
so what's what's your form of therapy
that you took from this book
oh man well what I took from the book it
it really
it really
caused me to re-look at what I did right
in my life and where I've screwed up and
how much of my time I I
this book is a real cautionary tale for
younger people to not waste so much time
giving to people that were takers I uh
now I I you don't want to handicap your
kids by making their life too easy I
always let
person who doesn't
have any that's so much
to kind of out
s with like quotes and analogies and
stuff you know to act like you're smart
uh
who's going to have to go through their
own journey and I
and I uh is a great singer you know
you know I really hope though that
people can learn from the Giants and
this book I credit every person that I
can think of for things that I've
learned in
the band when you have to write a book I
I didn't realize how hard recording your
own audiobook actually is riffing like
this is easy talking in front of a group
of five thousand people is easier than
recording the audiobook so I spent three
days in a studio so
this book
the Same by line which I mean I put so
much work into writing this book that
with help from other people and going
through my life and my
the atmospheric conditions you know I
mentioned Dr Don Wood in the book and
he's sitting here in the room which is
great so thank you for that contribution
and you just have to evaluate your life
anyone doing a podcast
on stage anywhere like doing this stuff
I say this jokingly and seriously
we want you know there's low self-esteem
and low self-worth for me and I know
people to like me I hope people like my
ideas I hope it's it's it's inspiring
and at the same time
if I don't do this what am I left with
you know because having an Insight or an
awareness but not putting it out into
the world seems like a real waste uh and
so everyone here has a book everyone
here has the ability to influence
someone and
I'm curious to see when I put the book
out into the wild and we start getting
some negative reviews what those are
going to be and how it's going to impact
beer if I'll even give a crap you know
but I'm just uh I'm just happy that I
was able to go back over my whole life
and what I came away with is the
importance of first dominoes the
importance of
protecting my time and how much of my
time I wasted
giving to takers
I wasn't aware of it until I had to
document it until I had to I was
completely oblivious to it and and now
I'm on a mission to really help uh
givers not be taken in by takers and I
want genius Network My Real Genius
Network I teach
at work is anyone could develop a genius
at work in some area of Life a
connection network with a group of
people to help you with whatever it is
you're you're trying to do
the genius I work here is I want some of
the most amazing industry transforming
entrepreneurs that are also givers to
come together and be most helpful to
each other and we try to smoke out
narcissists and things like that and
there are narcissists to join this group
I mean it's a
it's filled with givers man where givers
are like targets for narcissists they're
just looking for them and
I mean those of you that identify your
I mean
they can't man they just
there are predators out there that are
looking for people that are you are
useful so that they can they can plug
their you know they can plug into your
electrical field
fine because
you're an energy vessel we're all energy
vessels it's just don't be depleted so
the book helped me a better boundary
myself
into this okay
you know how am I going to approach all
this stuff
I love it well the man is Joe polish the
book is what's in it for them we'll do
some q a but first let's give them a
round of applause
well I've known you for like 11 or 12
years and
hundreds and hundreds of people who know
you
and
I want to address something you have
talked about as a theme through
you today where you talk about
taking from people
contributing to people first and
creating value
there's an aspect of that where I think
it's very easy to for people to
misunderstand it get
there to
a place of General
generations
and one of the things that I've seen
about you
without strident
that
I know many
mental consist
ENT about how your generosity is is
given without any expectation of
anything coming back to you
so
I just wanted to ask if you had anything
to say about drawing that distinction
between giving us a strategy which is
more
more as compared to giving because you
have something to contribute and the
love of contributing and the experience
you get from contributing and the karmic
aspect of that is that in return
result of the trust that people
establishing you they want to be
connected they want to engage with you
and do business with you thank you for
the question there was a guy named Ralph
Bloss who owned a company called
steamway which was selling uh chemicals
and equipment and truck mount carpet
cleaning machines two carpet cleaners
and when I had long-haired a ponytail uh
and I was this young guy you know
running ads that I'm going to teach you
how to build and grow your carpet
cleaning business and I was selling
really
a pretty hard Edge because I was
constantly being attacked I was young
and there were people that were twice my
age and I
this industry and just completely
disrupted because I was teaching them
direct response marketing and no one was
an expert in direct response Marketing
in the carpet cleaning industry and
Ralph boss was the first guy that
recommending that he had distributors
have me come and speak and teach to all
of their you know cleaners and he was
really encouraging he just wanted to do
because he was like this guy that just
helped he just wanted to help like his
customers and help his clients and he
would just wonderful salt of the earth
people right and
I developed a really good relationship
with him he was the nicest guy and he
would take time to help people and he
was such a caring person and I really
admired that uh
and when I went to his funeral a lot of
people showed up
and the number one thing that was said
over and over again uh when people got
up and talked about it was how he
encouraged them what
and I was like you know that's what I
hope to do in my life I just hope to
encourage enough people as I can and if
I come at it from a taker sort of place
or a gift to get sort of place or
at this point
number you know
each body
I did an interview
at the time I think it was 47 years old
and it's funny because today I'm you
know I'm 54 years old right now and I
said you know how do you stay in
good physical shape run into business
and do an awesome I'll start doing and
you're
he goes you know it's kind of my
business now I'm kind of incongruent if
I don't do it so I'm sort of in a
position where people expect me to you
know it kind of makes me behave myself a
little bit maybe I don't know
but the other side of it is I feel I
feel creepy when I feel like I'm
operating from the taker energy I I've
gotten a set
and I say all of this not saying that's
the best thing there are certain
situations where you just you know the
situation demands that you be mercenary
and you go and do what you need to do I
mean if it's a life or death situation
if it's a war situation you you know
know save your kid your kid or save your
life or do what needs to be done I hope
that those situations are only
infrequent so that one can operate but
I'm really pursuing a
people I don't want
it with people there's connecting where
you connect by conning people and then
there's connecting when you're genuinely
connecting and I can I I don't like the
conduct or energy and
and you take people
often they'll talk about being authentic
authentic and they'll do these
superly nice edited videos
tone of voice and the peaceful monk-like
energy and all that
they're full of crap they're just full
of crap and they're they're connecting
and they say right then they're
inspiring the people that don't know
that
so I'm not saying that
in their good services I mean there are
some really just
people that inspire people that never
know that they're
designed I grew up with this stuff all
the time
yeah
I don't know if that answered anything
with you seems like whatever whatever
you've done it
product marketing and Juice Network GSX
so if you had that book when you started
all of that what's
what's pitfalls and dead ends or hurt do
you think that if you had that book then
and you read that would have oh man I
waited way too long to do that book but
I also say that you know
there's a difference between forgiveness
and letting go I I think some people you
don't forgive them because they're still
causing hurt and and you're kind of
kidding yourself it's like when I
interviewed Dr romini davasala here a
couple times
uh you know there's a difference between
forgiveness and letting go uh
forgiveness my favorite definition of
forgiveness is giving up the hope that
one day you'll have a better past
right so I you know I have to forgive
myself and say because I live
I wish I would have written a book 20
years ago I just never did it I
didn't
I didn't assemble the time to do it I
had too many Alibis as to why I couldn't
write a book and I wish I would have
done it and I'll tell you like if you
have a book inside you quit sitting on
it Hatchet you know it's like get it
done and figure out how to get help with
it if need be uh it would have been
really beneficial I I think uh it would
have helped me a lot and it was my own
journey I also I
get yourself up all the time for things
that I haven't done and I realize that
you know this is just my journey I'm
doing the best I can in my current level
of Consciousness so everything that I do
everything you know and I all I do say
this as a joke
and a bit of seriousness is I hope I
look back at this conversation 10 years
from today and say I can't believe I
said that stupid stuff I hope I evolve
and and I'm okay with the the
full put myself out there I will speak
my opinions and some of them may be
wrong some of them may be just stupid
and that's okay and humans do you know
do stupid things and then there are you
know there's uh there's I
I get current level of consciousness
couldn't have written this book in the
past
because if I could have I would have
so everything that we're doing right now
it's
when I first started going to 12-step
meetings
I heard the saying your best thinking
got you here so people would come in and
they're trying to fight it they think
they're smart and it's like okay smarty
pants your life is unmanageable it's
spinning out of control your best
thinking got you here you're so
intelligent
and so I have to realize my best
thinking got me here I just need to keep
improving my thinking
and uh but if I would have been able to
do that in the past man
I I wish I would have had this book
you know 20 years ago because I really
wrote This Book
what I wish I would have
had when I first started out it
was much pain and so much
that's what I hope it does for anyone
and to sign the matter how old someone
is I think you know
that we do in life that doesn't involve
other people in relationships
uh giving away all my talents and my
Tammy my time attention money effort and
energy to people that were on um
I don't know if I would say under
human level because because I think all
humans are
observefully deservative care and love
it's just some people's behavior is
Despicable and some people there are
people on the planet that are evil not a
lot
I think there's a lot of
people that make bad decisions but there
are truly
a very small percentage of people that
are like the Joker they just want to
watch the world burn and a lot of them
are in control of the world right now in
very high places very power position so
uh
have many versions of those people and
if I would have had a book early on
a waiver and I would have been less
gullible and susceptible to being sold
in
hypey things
and
you know believing people just because
they happen to
be able to trigger
Peterson is floating around here
somewhere but marketers have a very
unique way of being able to stop time in
the moment
feel inadequate
you know like you're not old enough
you're not young enough you're not thin
enough you're not rich enough you're not
this enough for that you know you got
hemorrhoids you got acne you got too
much hair in your body your skin
like every type of marketing message is
about how inadequate you are
a person and it's like man you can
believe that book and this is like
everyone's running I'm terrified
everyone's running around hoping people
like like them that they look okay and
as you know as we get older as we get
whatever you know there's all kinds of
you know Society has this way of framing
you know Beauty and desirability and
marketers know how to go right into
those desires and twist them and tweak
them and stuff like that and if I would
have been more aware that I wouldn't
have been taken in so much by it
I Love Your Capacity to give and how you
did it's really the joy of life and I
feel like with all the struggle right
now with a lot of people that are really
just trying to get through
what is it's hard to think about helping
others when you're when you're stuck at
trying to just get in your in your out
of your own way so what's one what's one
thing that you think that people like
that should start with to get to get to
what's in it for them to
over their
Muslim as much as one
if you're in a a really
and I'll say that's not like you but I'm
just saying in general people
if you're in a really hurting place like
even
one of the best
will change environments right get off
the couch get out of bed move even if
you have to drag yourself through
quicksand in order to do
it I mean mustard whatever
willpower you can but you know in that
Hollowell my my friend who's the you
know the ADD ADHD psychiatrist you know
he has a three-step worry plan which is
uh you know get the facts uh have a plan
like if you're do I have cancer well
find out do you have cancer so you know
get the facts you know and have a plan
and the other one is uh don't worry it
won't so so you know we oftentimes
silent battles are the hardest battles
to fight and so what I've learned from
addiction recovery is I've never met a
true addict that ever recovered in
isolation they have to do connection
they have to do it through other people
if you think your life sucks I wrote
something called how to have a great day
according to me
not me but Joe polish is what it was
called how to navigate
to
polish
egotistical smart ass back in the early
days of marketing and um
not that that's changed I just learned
how to protected one yeah so
um but um
one of the things I said I listed like
20 things that you can do on how to have
a great day which is eat
healthy food exercise move meditate
inspiring write a letter to yourself and
mail it to yourself so three or four
days later you get this letter in the
mail giving yourself a pep talk if you
have then I said at the end P.S if none
of this works for you go volunteer at a
children's hospital an animal shelter a
homeless shelter Recovery Clinic because
helping other people if you think that's
the weirdest thing about recovery is
if you don't give a
give it all a lot of people look like oh
you're just this really nice sweet
person because you do all this stuff
with addicts and recovery and yeah I
mean I it does it makes an impact I know
it does I mean it
because I have this game that can go
really dark and if I don't do this sort
of stuff I might go and that you know I
don't know it's biochemical I don't know
what it is uh
uh you know it's not just like some
philanthropic Angel here it's that's not
it it's like I benefit from giving to
people as much as they benefit from
whatever I give
being for me I don't want to say
everyone else should be this way you
know some people seem to do very well by
being selfish pricks
think karmically
um I I think life gives to the giver
takes him to take her I think there will
be a point in time when you know if you
spend your life leaving scorched Earth I
think it catches up with you
and so I think if you're really down and
out it really hard to move because the
issues are in the tissues you know in
any really good trained trauma person
will tell you that and when you're stuck
you the way to get unstuck is to move
is to breathe is to get into the body
and try to find that flow State you know
that flow State whatever that is for for
people where you just feel that real
connection
is where Nirvana is where Bliss is where
uh the best parts of life live most of
the time we're not going to be there but
if we can just get small slices of it
here and there it can dramatically
improve your ability to be helpful and
not fall into
great conversation Evan uh great
questions Joe thanks for sharing all
this with us I think it's it's What
attracted me to genius
I used to believe in coincidences
and then just through lots of giving
amazing things started to happen right
just like you're like how how did I end
up on a private island with these cool
people
was part of my story and anyway I I
wonder what your thoughts around
reciprocity are Joe because you know the
more that you give the more people
psychologically want to reciprocate
which is such a fascinating concept like
wait now I owe Joe something because he
just did something nice to me and so how
have you noticed
reciprocity playing out in your life
as you know I mean I'm sure that's a
core element of the book and
um of sort of your motto on living but
can you speak to reciprocity and how
that's
um you know what your perspective around
reciprocity has been yeah yeah well
first off I I love the idea of
reciprocity I first learned uh a lot
about it through Dr Robert chaldini who
I've known now for uh three decades and
it's funny he read my entire book gave
me a really great testimony and one
thing also I have to mention most books
have testimonials from um people that
have never read the book and one of the
things that I did with this book because
it would go against what I teach in the
book about what I consider integrity and
ethics is uh if someone wants to give a
character testimonial or if they're
familiar with someone's content and they
can write a testimonial about that great
I think it's inauthentic though to write
a testimonial about a book that you have
not read and so I get probably 10
requests a week for people wanting me to
give book blurs and I'm like I first off
I'm a slow reader even though Jim quick
has tried to teach me how to read faster
and he gave me a great testimonial for
the book I think it took him like 12
seconds to read it
so there's not a single testimonial
that's on the book uh from someone that
has not read the whole book and I even
had um you know even Tony Robbins had
they had sent an email to me asking for
writing three blurs and I was like no
I'm not writing any blurbs and uh only
if you read the whole book and you write
the testimony or yourself so it's like
I'm not so it's one of the things with
that
um and damn it I'm forgetting the
question again is reciprocity yeah thank
you Jesus so here's what's funny Robert
chaldini reads the book gives me a
glowing testimonial and then bobbette
who also read the whole book and gave me
a testimonial they called me up and say
hey can we take you out to dinner and
share with you everything that we did
because we've sold over 5 million copies
of influence and we got some ideas for
you and I'm like you could imagine I
never would have imagined that in in
like here's the reciprocity influence
expert you know having reciprocity with
me and feeling just wanting to help me I
was like man I've done something right
here and even Stephen pressfield who's
one of my favorite authors in the world
read the whole book and gave me a great
testimonial which is one of my I'm just
bragging now so anyway I'll start with
that in terms of reciprocity
um it is very important and I like
reciprocal people what I've learned
about reciprocity though is you can
either engineer it and use it as a
strategy which is easy to do in business
and I can even teach a couple techniques
if you guys want to learn that or you
can approach it to where you've
demonstrated giving and it just instills
the reciprocity now reciprocity like
anything it's the tool and it's the the
intention behind it one thing I write
about you know Stephen covey's talked
about this other people have talked
about it is people judge themselves on
their intentions and they judge others
by their actions
and so uh and yeah I have a friend like
if I ask someone here how many in the
room have been screwed by somebody
before
okay
how many of you in the room have screwed
other people okay a couple of people not
as many but yeah well so the people are
like well you know why were you screwed
but you haven't screwed anyone else it's
because every person that screwed you if
you ask them
they they wouldn't see it that way some
of them might be really aware people
know when they make mistakes and it
takes a lot of awareness to make amends
and say I screwed up you know usually
that just that comes through you know
really self-reflection and awareness but
with reciprocity uh if your intention is
to be really helpful
the benefit of being helpful and
generous is people are reciprocal
they're going to want so my whole thing
if you look at my genius Network tool
where we write the names of people in
the genius Network and then you list the
names you know uh who are they
how can I help them so who are they
what's the value and capability they
have how can I help them and how can
they help me I want everyone to get help
from all of the stuff that you're doing
for other people but I want the focus to
be what's in it for them not what's in
it for me and so reciprocity if you
really think about how can I be helpful
and and I'm going to give something
somebody wants I'm going to show up with
a give that get that that satiates or
surpasses their want and if you do that
then a reciprocal person will feel
appreciated they will feel appreciated
for you and they will want to help you
without you having to trick them now
some people can say well are you
tricking them if you're instilling
reciprocity well not if you're giving
them what they want not if you're being
useful and like let's take me and Dan
Sullivan I'm a very reciprocal person
Dan is a very reciprocal person more
people are ingenious that work from his
referrals than any other referral source
there are currently only 380 pain
members of Genius Network I mean of
strategic coach that I have referred
into the program
like and I don't get an affiliate
commission for that he pays me for my
group I pay him for his group I think
it's a good group I refer people to it
if people come to me and say should I
join genius I work a strategic coach
just out of like the way we it's like
joined strategic coach let them help you
get your life together and they'll send
back to me a better genius Network
member and when people ask him he says
the same thing no go to genius.work
first and then when you're ready you
come to strategic it's a very reciprocal
relationship and me and Dan are
completely different in so many ways but
we have a shared value system with
reciprocity but in the beginning you
know if someone really is just doing it
because they want to get something
that's they're trying to they're trying
to use reciprocity as a trick like and
I'll say this last thing since about
reciprocity when I was a carpet cleaner
I I read influence and one of the
studies because
um Robert cialdini studied all kinds of
people in what he would call the
compliance industry sales people
televangelists con artists people that
had to enroll people into everything
from insurance to political you know you
name it and it was in the getting people
to comply and and what's funny is I've
got BJ fog one of the top behavioral you
know researchers and professors in the
world Chris Voss who's now the top
negotiation guy and Robert cialdini the
top influence guy all three of them have
read my book and gave me great
testimonials that to me is like the
coolest thing ever and they're so much
smarter in all these areas and so uh
when I first read uh influence by Robert
cialdini and all of you can use this by
the way what I'm about to share it's you
know because I know this whole thing's
been talking about me
um so uh he had before 9 11 and stuff in
airports airports were way more free
with what people could do and so there
were Hari krishners that would ask for
donation they would wear the robes the
maroon and I guess what like yellow
orange and and they would ask for
donations and people you know obviously
became aware of that and so they would
avoid them and so then they realized
well if they just wear normal clothes uh
and have a woman do it it was less
confrontational or threatening than a
man and they would have these little
flowers and so they would take these
little flowers and someone would be
walking through the airport and they
would literally go as usually a woman
would go up to him guys I'd like to give
you a gift and you know they're they're
dressed normal they have a basket of
flowers and they want to give a gift and
they would put the gift and say let me
give you that flower and then the person
would you know usually not say no no no
and and they would say well thank you
and they say would you like to make a
donation and what they found is that
nine out of ten people would reach into
their pocket pull out a dollar or two
for a gift that they didn't even want
and give them money because it was
harder to say I didn't want this and
you're using this to trick me right now
and give it back so what the people
would do is then they'd walk away and
when they were out of view of the person
that the the woman that had given them
the flower they would throw the flower
in the trash and they go on to their
gate so they're playing and then about
every hour or so they would go to the
trash can get all the flowers and do it
all over again
until like everyone was hip to that sort
of trick and this was decades ago now
right this was probably like 40 years
ago and
so I was like thinking okay if you can
get recipe if reciprocity works by
giving something to somebody that for
something they don't even want imagine
how well it would work if you actually
gave something to somebody that they did
want and I'm like and you used it in an
ethical way because that was conning
people that was a bull that was
engineered reciprocity which is a term
from uh Abraham and so I started giving
away a free room of carpet cleaning uh
no cost for obligation of any kind let
me try this and I ended up not only
making more money giving away a free
room of carpet cleaning and doing what I
call the carpet audit which was
different than a quote or an estimate
because everyone was giving quotes and
giving estimates and I realized that
everything marketing wise is unique
packaging and positioning is how you
bundle it it's how you package it it's
how you offer it it's how you
communicate it and so when I started
doing that and then I started teaching
other carpet cleaners so literally
hundreds of millions of dollars of of
carpet cleaning have been sold for
higher prices
by using my free room and carpet
cleaning method in the most thorough
cleaning ever it's free and all this
other stuff I did in the cleaning
industry years ago and I used
reciprocity in that way but I did it
with people that actually wanted it not
people that I was bribing but you can
use reciprocity in very evil ways and
people do it they even I mean even with
the vaccine they were offering kids like
ice cream and lollipops to go get a
vaccine so there's all kinds of ways to
use reciprocity in uh in effective ways
and well evil ways are good ways I guess
I would put it
you answered part of my question about
testimonials but I'm really I'm really
curious to hear what
my sister you've talked a lot about
yourself uh What uh since you Evan's
worked with you a lot is
so I I read the book I want to read the
book obviously no important was that Joe
got a super early Advanced copy with all
the mistakes and like testimony will be
here and all that stuff
I love the Frameworks you know because
from my perspective what Joe did kind of
seemed like magic right it's like well
why am I so incentivized help this guy
who's going to be away for a year
yeah why do I care so much and I just
know that it worked but the book
actually gives some of the formulas for
how to do it some of the concepts that I
the idea of like a pain detective I
hadn't heard I haven't heard you ever
say that like in conversations but he
has it in the book and it's like the
three questions that you need to ask if
you are a pain detective to figure out
somebody's pain point so it makes it at
least for me a lot of you I like the
Frameworks I like the thinking they can
say oh it's like that that's a thought
behind the magic so if you're trying to
at least for me to build my network up
better and be better
indicator I find a lot of tools super
helpful and just tried to bring some of
my next level of questions here so
hopefully it was valuable for you guys
too I've been
teaching leadership for the last 12
years so I've come across so many
different kind of personalities and
especially when you're writing an event
there's people who are in service and
they're giving
and notice people who
are giving out of significance
they want to be seen
but they're also wanting some aspect of
their life and business to grow and it's
kind of like stopped and there's other
people that the giving seems so
effortless
um and it seems like things are always
flowing in their life but for the people
who you notice that are giving out of
significance it's like I did this and I
did this and I did this for this person
what's your conversation if you notice
that in your workplace like how do you
like approach that conversation meaning
when someone's giving but they're not
being effective they're not they're
they're giving they're not being
effective and you know that they're
giving just so other
job
that's the thing yeah that's a that's an
interesting one and by the way anything
I will say here I am working on
honorable to people the
attempt them to put me on a hierarchy or
to it's the weirdest thing like when I
go uh and give a talk and I will have
sometimes people come up and ask for
pictures or an autograph for me and they
will be trembling and I will say to them
if you knew how many personal
would be nothing but
it's weird because
because you can actually control people
people with their perceived perspective
you I see celebrities do that all the
time and I just
hit right and because of that though I
all I often
will not um position myself well I'll
I'll make myself too accessible you know
Dan Kennedy's the polar opposite of that
sort of behavior like he works
intimidate
people feel uncomfortable in his
presence I mean
persona but I don't like doing that
stuff
that stuff what I what do you
want to use there's a lot of
water it's one of the things too about
that Mark
you really do have
teaching teachers don't make as much
money as salespeople
so you can be a teacher but you also
have to from a economic standpoint
there's that part of you that asks you
see
it is a lot easier to get a standing
ovation than it is to get people to pull
out a credit card and buy you
and I if you judge the value of your
delivery to an audience based on how
many people applaud you and like you
versus pay you it's the wrong metrics of
impact now
the challenge with that is people that
are selling crap in a box are really
good at manipulative selling justify
that the crap that they're selling
people is they really need it and
someone's going to buy it anyway so it
might as well be me and they're going to
give the money to someone else there's
you know
numerous conversations with with these
people for years and years and years and
so there is a point in time where people
don't value themselves and
and like the so let's take the result
leader
leader like there's a lot of people that
want to be viewed as thought leaders
want to be made as influencers but I
always have to say
what are you an influence and what the
hell does a thought leader mean because
you know there's uh it says up here you
know somewhere via a result leader not a
thought leader um
is it right behind me
which one yeah result leader not taught
leader thank you uh
if you produce results in your job in
your business for your clients for other
people
and you don't tap into the value of that
result and you undervalue it then you
are going to get treated uh you're going
to be disrespected yeah and people treat
you the way you train them to treat you
and for all the lives that I have
to jump I have to also
somehow trade and
and I had to really take a look at a lot
of that and everything in this book and
figuring out what that is and then
trying to explain it so other people can
actually see here's where I made a
mistake
mistake it was part of my journey to you
know to do that so I would tell that
person to you know what do you bring to
the table and develop the child see with
Joe Weldon there's a lot of people here
that have enormous talent and skill but
they don't know how to communicate it in
a way to where people comprehend it and
take it in because there's
you know people say content is King
context is King you got to have good
content communication is valuable but
comprehensions even more valuable if I
was in a struggle with something and you
had the solution to it but you were
communicating that solution to me in
Japanese I don't speak Japanese I don't
understand Japanese you might be telling
me exactly what I needed to know and
communicate in it to me but I couldn't
comprehend it so part of it is people
just they haven't comprehended to
themselves what they actually bring to
the table and they undervalue themselves
and that's where I think this book will
be helpful that's where it looks like uh
you know went into intimidation by
Robert ringer would be really valuable
that's an amazing book and it wasn't a
book teaching people how to be how to
intimidate other people it was a book
that teaches people how to
protect yourself against people that
want to intimidate you until I write
about that in this book uh is like
beware of people that are trying to
intimidate you and how they position you
so positioning is really valuable and
really helpful and oftentimes it's like
wrong
book influence
the book after that was persuasion
because he said the moment of influence
is more impacted by what you do before
the moment of influence than by the
moment of influence so people are always
trying to learn how to implement s and
it's like what do you do beforehand
is really good at helping people with
introduction right how are you framed
because I remember Joel telling me this
if you have a beautiful painting a very
valuable painting that really could be
in the Louvre and it's you know whatever
and you duct tape it to the wall in a
dark side of your in the hallway versus
in an art museum in a nice frame with
lighting and people pay to go in there
it's a different experience Derek sivers
uh
of the book called the music book
I'll try to find the chapter and read it
to you guys uh tomorrow it's a very
short chapter but he talks about like
this promotion
uh like if you had a feather
uh and and you just had like a feather
and it was I think like sitting uh like
on the wall or something that's just a
feather but if you put it in
it's you know hung it
did the Crawford to like a tunnel or
something
or something it's the same
synthetics that you did beforehand to
make it seem like oh my God if you've
ever gone into a
movie and you're like
okay why is it here but you see some
people that think it's the most amazing
thing ever because they're still under
the delusion of this like insanity of
the art world but the you know the
hardest level
you know it's um
too
it's enthusiasm Dave kakachada which is
his enthusiasm covers many deficiencies
so people that don't know what the hell
they're talking about or what they're
doing if they can at least show up in a
very enthusiastic manner they can still
off and you have enthusiasm with it
you're going to come across as more
powerful and more desirable if you have
the greatest solution in the world and
you care and you're just legit person
and you show up with no enthusiasm
you're going to get
responsive enthusiasm
he has incredibility
isn't as valuable in today's day and age
is believability
there are many people that have no
credibility
they are really good at marketing and
hyping and convincing people and people
believe them
look at the last two years how much
has been fed to people that believed it
when there was no
Michael bernoff in his book he talks
about food is there's
addiction
there's entertainment and there's
nutrition so a lot of the food that
people eat is it's either nutrition or
It's Entertainment or it's addiction and
a lot of the information that people are
fed is not
it's not just package up that way
the most expensive information in the
world is bad information even if it's
free
thank you for asking yeah of course do
you remember the question no okay
that question kind of follows so as a
love coach I mean Matt being successful
relationships always has one person that
represents the sacred polarity of
person that represents
and say what's in it for them and so
um
what I've noticed is there's two swaths
in the population people who are really
good at honoring their needs and wants
and representing them is a
so this book is really I want to know
what do you say to people and what will
they learn from your book if they
struggle to see what's in it for
themselves rather than the other person
people who often negotiate
negotiate themselves out of what's best
for them
people how to they're already good at
what's in it for them they need to
figure out what's in it for themselves
rather than the other because that's
really important and I know you're good
at that okay so you're saying if they're
in a situation where they're just giving
giving giving but they're not they're
not
considering their own
reflection barter codependent
or Matt game yeah how do you help them
that's a really good question let me
think how to do it at secretly so I
don't do what I just sit with Garrett
didn't like it around
foreign
of why you're doing this what does the
person really need what do they really
want
in the book
I write about
if you
if you have a child that really wants
dogs and donuts and candy and stuff
and if you just give that child what
they want
what's in it for them
you're not really helping your child
you're kind of hurting them
now if someone is
stranded without food
and the most nutritious food you think
you could give them as maybe like a
pound of broccoli but there's no other
food
giving them a pound of fudge
for sugar and fat and fat is actually
going to be a better
it's gonna it's gonna sustain them it's
going to keep them alive right
for people that are constantly giving
and they're not getting stuff or they're
all over the map and they're not they're
just unclear you know the the sun is
always
when the sun is out it's just oftentimes
there are clouds in the way so as people
approach activity and they're just
spinning and they're what it is is you
can't confuse activity with
accomplishment so yeah
part of this
is not being long enough to
am I just giving myself away or just
trying to get external validation or
have people like me or am I really
trying to accomplish something here
because actually the more selective you
are
and that's a tough thing to understand
is where I just want to be available to
everyone I want to sell to everyone
everyone will benefit from my thing but
the more you Niche it the more impact
you're going to make the deeper you're
going to go so I would say you know same
thing with reading books you'd be better
off mastering one book like this one uh
versus reading like 50 books or or
listening to 50 podcasts
have to leave with it and so I mean
people you know really don't need a
bunch of relationships in their life you
only need a full a few Tools in your
toolbox in order to make an impact but
you know part of it is like
he taught me years and I've done
I've done it is you get a
pen and paper and you write 10 things
you want every day and just do it every
day for like a month and you don't look
at what you wrote the previous day
the first couple of weeks of doing this
and I've had groups do this I've done it
myself many times over the years the
first week or two you're writing all
kinds of random stuff but after a couple
of weeks you actually start writing the
same you you start honing in and getting
clear on what you want and by me talking
about this it's not the same as you guys
and it's really weird how you know like
forms and tools are just ways to take
your random thoughts and ideas and
organize them and not have to be all
over the place and so
yeah I mean I think just asking yourself
what do I really want what's the best
outcome that will come out of this and
what's gonna what's the elegant idea
here and then you don't just yeah it's
just it's not fake work most of the work
that's done in the world is
it's just being really busy
of the sabbatical played an integral
part in the
end and if you reach creative blocks is
there anything that you did to get out
of that during the process
what kind of A and B questions
um yeah it's a lot easier to make
personal decisions when you're not
you're not birded by so many business
decisions and one thing is one of my
lessons is um
which we just put it actually up on Joe
sabbatical.com we put a talk that I gave
at Michael Fishman's consumer health
Summit Michael's downstairs right now um
is
not being on social media is more
inspiring to me than reading
inspirational quotes on social media
and so when I when I blocked a lot of
the stuff into this day uh you know I
have my phone behind me
I just spoke or LinkedIn or
Instagram definitely not Tick Tock you
know unless unless you like your entire
life being analyzed by China all day
long
um you know I don't have any social
media apps on there so uh in term
S I wish I I've had quite a few
conversations Stephen Cutler about this
who's you know done a lot of stuff with
flow
uh
you know they're
I I get to the to exercise I think one
of the greatest things that I did and I
started doing it with uh Cherie is cold
plunging and saunas
most daily
and that really it's biochemical stuff I
mean it's like whatever you know because
full state to me is is being engaged and
feeling connected and I think I get into
a flow Stadium business
when I'm just talking about ideas with
people and when I'm helping people you
know when I when I I really feel if I
can help someone with some sort of issue
that that I know is a caring person that
there'll be some benefit I just feel
really good about that and
you know because you can give yourself
lives it's like the question Andy was
asking you know oftentimes uh you know
you that's the complicated thing with
having a foundation it's
to charge anything to people that
struggle with addictions because so many
people with addictions and what sold to
them is very exploitive and then on the
other end of the spectrum I want to deal
with players with money that are really
high level people
to join you know my programs and stuff
and uh
so uh yeah just
addiction is
very similar to a flow State it's just
an artificial one
you know because when you're in the
bubble and you're acting out
with work or sex or gambling
or anger or
status addiction performance addiction
where you're just trying to you know but
that could be
that sort of performance in the
and then man you feel like you're in a
flow statement it's a it's a mirage it's
a
the real flow States come usually
through
through real you know like the endorphin
high that someone gets from extreme
exercise you know the reason why porn is
so heavily addictive is sexual activity
is very few things that can jump you to
that level of endorphins like it unless
you want to go run a minimum of two
miles and
it's too painful so you know it's really
easy to look at the internet
and and get these you know brushes and
so but taking time
all of the work you don't realize how
much
you put up with until you walk away from
it for a while
and I didn't realize how capable my team
was to keep a company going including I
mean think about this business like you
know
a physical sort of business or like a
master Minecraft is right like uh oh
Master you know I don't even like I
don't even think of this as a mastermind
and definitely do Mastermind in here but
it's more of a connection network
you know where you have a business that
is my business based around me running
it and being able to step away from it
but I had to get to that place where you
know even if it crashed it didn't work I
I was I was okay with that you know I
got offered two hundred thousand dollars
to do a one hour
posture in my sabbatical that I turned
down but I went and spoke for free at
the Salvation Army uh to 80 men and
women that were in a six-month treatment
program and I felt way more
psychologically better that in a bigger
flow statement if I would have taken the
money and violated
it said to myself uh you know about that
so but if you've never read uh even the
original book by mahali chick sent me
high the flow the psychology of
achievement he died a few years ago uh
that guy was definitely onto something
and
amazing book
about about flow and when I was uh when
I was a drug addict the only thing that
helped me get to a flow State other than
drugs was doing ceramics and the dummy
that I am I
I never picked it back up
holding Ceramics a few times so that's
one of the things that's on my list like
on yep I need to start throwing pots
again
because when I was in with the clay and
yeah you know I threw there's something
about it yeah yeah it's different that
you should chopping up you know coke
with a snorting stuff that's a different
sort of pottery but it's like
that was a bad answer to that question
thank you
number one thank you so much for writing
the book Thank you I want to turn around
and go back
uh the light on forgiveness
I've been I give her all my life I just
was born like that I have you know I
didn't work that was just like that and
I've been taken to the cleaners a lot of
times and the hardest time was about 11
year advantage of me I wanted him as a
business partner he was a client in any
ways I ended up losing a lot of money
but I didn't care about the money I care
about the emotional Affliction that he
created my heart and it took me three
years to forgive
thank God my lawyer told me instead of
pursuing Allah so that he told me to use
that money and that effort to get better
clients and that's what I did
so
the biggest mistake in my life is
closing my heart
right and I I will never take those two
years back
so I finally was able to forgive and
then I opened my heart again and I was
so my question to you is how do you
actually accelerate the process of
forgiveness when you get taken to the
cleaners
wow okay the there's the politically
correct answer of like you know do
therapy and and all that which is is
helpful right and and and and hang
around uh givers and uh remove takers
from your life and down
breathe
meditate reflect learn
um
the things that Maria talked about
earlier today I think would be a good
process there's you know quite a few
people here in the group that would
probably be very capable of answering
the Forgiveness thing to me because I
people
kind of screwed me over
it not that I want to go want to go and
hurt them or whatever even
or even think about that in my brain
like I I I
ruminate
like one of my biggest challenges with
addiction is is not the
you know I'll explain this through the
field of addiction so the addiction
cycle is preoccupation where you're
thinking about it then there's
ritualization let me
let me it's preoccupation there's
ritualization where you have rituals
around the behavior the drugs the things
you do then there's the compulsive act
where you're actually drinking drugging
sex gambling or gaming
and then once you
once you pulsive
[Music]
app then you go into Despair and when
you're in a state of despair
shame and guilt
s and then when you're in shame and
guilt the way to get out of Despair is
to start the whole damn cycle over again
so fixating and closing your heart with
anger and rage when so what's so screwed
you over
the thing that really hurts the most is
that not only closing yourself off but
the preoccupation where you're reliving
it you really it's like the trauma Bond
right where you're reliving the trauma
you know the site and getting that
to break that cycle I don't think you do
it alone I think you you need a way to
process you know the trauma is not the
thing that happened or the hurt it's
it's what happens after and how you
usually process
therapy and oftentimes a uh you know and
unfortunately there's there's only a
handful of places you can legally do it
in the United States is like plant
medicine Journeys and stuff you know
you know therapy of psilocybin things
like that those are actually uh quite
useful tools uh to use for uh trauma
that you know with the right person it
that's the key because there's a lot of
dangerous people that are out there
calling themselves Shaman that are you
know putting themselves in so I mean
this is uh not to be taken lightly I
mean you have to really do your research
and I'm happy to people in that
direction if they want to know
uh
it's ultimate process anyone that really
you know specializes in uh
my friend Dr Romney
and part of it is again from the things
that hurt him
you know the people that hurt you but
I'll tell you though I mean like you
said when you opened your heart back up
I mean you know the toughest shelves
hide the tenders meet
you know and oftentimes you know it's
it's the most man some of the most
compassionate people I've ever met are
people that have been look at look at
Andre Norman
I mean he got used to stab people and
running number three gang leader you
know now he's like a big teddy bear now
he's capable of hurting someone
physically like you know he could hurt
someone if he needed to because he's got
years of experience doing that but also
look at what
the pain did if it's if it's transmuted
in a good way so you know if if you
don't uh if you don't ever process uh my
father unfortunately when my mother died
he never recovered he was tormented the
rest of us
lived
early sad because he didn't have the
tools and I think he did the best of
course he did the best he did he could
that's all people can do even when you
know even the people that hurt us
you know in a lot of ways their
punishment is their own existence
you know when people screw you over
their punishment is what they did and uh
they're just their atmospheric
conditions somehow cause them to think
that you know hurting and betraying
someone was a smart thing to do and it's
sad so on one hand I feel sorry in
empathy for them
other times you know that's not a that's
no reasonable to
the pain that you're feeling but I think
definitely and here's the thing too
that's the beauty of making money if you
actually have like it was like I said
earlier not during this interview but
you know
people that say money can't buy
happiness haven't given enough of it
away I mean there's some people that
don't have the resources to even get
help
but there are therapists out and it you
know it takes cojones to walk into a
therapist's office or a group and say
I'm feeling really screwed up I'm a
really bright capable business person
over here and I lead people and people
look up to me and I'm
I don't know how to love someone I can't
even connect with someone in my own life
or even my kids I've got this wall and
talk of it you know and it's like most
people it's really hard for them to do
that
you know the therapist interviewed any
of you that have any sort of issues like
talk to him I'll give you his number do
a session with it pay him to do a
session you know that sort of stuff so I
I always try to you know I'll talk to
people tell people like read this book
or watch this video but really I think
it comes out of talking with other
people yeah like you know I wrote a book
with Anna David and how uh you know the
miracle morning prediction recovery
you don't recover from a book A book
just is a it's hopefully a domino it's a
seed but it's really doing the work it's
yeah you know doing the work and and
David Lynch uh he was angry it really
pissed off his whole life until he got
trained in Transcendental Meditation and
after two weeks of doing TM 20 minutes a
day twice a day after two weeks the
anger went away
and now he
he's got this whole Foundation that
my buddy Bob Ross you know runs it and
uh
they put in prison School
at times is just a meditative meditate
practice that allows you to find the
forgiveness
yeah I hope that helps Jason Campbell
would be great to talk with about that
and Annie Lala too those of you that
have any conflicts or relationship
issues she's expensive as hell but she's
she's good she's good okay I'm done sure
these people are probably tired so let
me let me say this
first off for doing this interview thank
you all for the questions and for even
being a client and I appreciate it and I
hope that you'll find the book really
valuable in that it explains things in a
much more
fashion because I had to write
the writing times
and then me just up here babbling for a
couple hours and if you like it I would
really appreciate it if you share it and
if it would be helpful to anyone that
you know allow me
ow me I'm doing a promotional thing
right here for now
I would love to support the book comes
out November 1st and if any of you want
to buy quantities of the book for your
clients or for your friends or for
Christmas or Thanksgiving or whatever
if you buy it retail price the proceeds
of the book go to genius recovery so
yeah so this book is
hopefully going to create a lot more
givers and it's going to help a lot of
people connect and it's it's a book on
character
it's not capabilities even though
there's a lot of capabilities in there
but my hope is that it will have people
question
stupid stuff and to be a more caring
person but to also protect yourself and
to not give it all away you know because
being a giver but not getting anything
for it is not going to help you you're
just going to deplete if you want to see
my last 101 with Joe polish check the
video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe I'll
see you then
make it count if you can't connect with
yourself it's going to be really hard to
connect with other people the scariest
thing that you're afraid to put out is
the thing that you have to go off and
share it's the only way two things in
business you don't delegate are the
marketing in the checkbook